So I got a lot of questions about our Greek mythology unit,
and we're about to start another round of Greek mythology unit
because the kids were loving it so much,
so I wanted to show you some of the resources
that I use to put it together.
The first thing I used was this Greek Mythology Unit study
that I got from Teachers Pay Teachers.
It is by Nicole Shelby, and it's for third and fourth grade.
It comes with great instructions for the teacher of how to,
you know, decorate your room,
how to go through the unit,
and then some close reading passages.
Um, this is one we did about all the Greek gods.
We don't always do it written down.
We do a lot of discussion work.
So, as you can see,
we did Hera,
but we ended up writing a lot of stuff during our discussion.
I always have written resources as well,
like physical books that I teach from.
Oh, they're my daughter's drawings of Athena and Hera.
I found this one in Barnes and noble,
and it was really great. It has kind of, um,
a lot of the ancient art as well that the kids can look at.
Our local library, we found these.
Choose your adventure based on Greek mythology. Perseus, um,
Hades and the Olympians, first Titans,
as well as a book on Athena,
which ended up being my daughter's favorite.
So with homeschooling, it's really important to find a Balance.
So we did this unit study, um,
this was really heavy on social studies and ELA,
so we didn't really do tons of math or science with it.
The important thing for us
then is to focus on those subjects for the following week
to make sure we're balancing out
how much they're getting exposed to all the curriculum.
Right now, we are doing a math unit on financial literacy.
I have a book that we got off Amazon
that's going through financial literacy lessons with the kids.
It is this one. And we are also starting back with our chemistry.
But the great thing about homeschooling is
you can lean in
when your kids are particularly interested in something.
So although I didn't plan to continue on with Greek mythology,
we are just about to start another unit on Greek mythology
in heroes and creatures and monsters.
And if you want another video about that unit,
I would be happy to share my resources there, too.